仏教でちょっと重点を置くんですね
個人のところに 自分の努力に
なぜならばそれは大事な決まり手なんですね
いくら母親がおいしいものを作ってくれても
父親が必要な分 勉強に必要な道具を全部揃えてあげたっても
特別室の部屋まで作ってくれたっても
立派な先生がついてくれても
やっぱり本人の努力っていうのはもう大事なポイントなんですね
ですから それから個人の主観的な原因っていうのはいくらでも調整できる
客観的な原因は調整できる
できなか ちょっとできないのがほとんどなんですね
私はもう一つ例えを言ったんですね
例えば畑を作ると で 畑作る農民の人には
まあ畑は平らにしたり
水をあげて それいじったり
雑草を取ったり 種を植えたりする
それしかできないんですね
それから立派にできて
いい作物取れるか取れないかっていうことは
自分の権力以外のことなんですね
両方合わせたらいい作物は出てくる
いずれも崩れちゃったらちょっと結果が良くないし
そこで農業やってる人にとっては
自分の努力っていうのは決して欠かせないことなんですね
だからそこら辺にちょっと重点を置くんです
ということは ちゃんと時期に雨が降って
ものすごい栄養ある土地があっても
種が植えなかったら何も出てこないんだから
全て揃ってあっても そういう風に因縁
適当な因縁っていうのはそこのそこら辺なんです
本当すっごい複雑なんです
で あの花を見て腹が立つか
面白くて笑うかっていう場合も
面白くて笑っちゃったら欲の心
不善心の 腹が立ったら不善心の怒りの心
だからあれ なんでそうなるかというと
そのそこら辺の因縁によります
だから怒るのは良くないんだから
私も花を見てて面白くなるそうと思っても面白くない
で 花を見て面白く笑う人は面白く笑うのは馬鹿らしいだから今度はもう賢く花が見たら怒るそうと思ったっても怒れないしね
だからそこら辺 すごく複雑なところなんです
そのヘイトって あの邪魔な全部ヘイトたちなんですね
因がある 原因なんですね
その因っていうのはどうかって決まって
それはもっと先までやろうと
その因と結構決まっちゃうわけですよ
その人しかその人のしかたでいい宗教になるかは決まっちゃうんですね
そのヘイトっていうのも
やっぱりそういう何かコントロールできるのができない
そういうのを簡単に言えばこの心の流れなんですから
この心の流れという法則
仏教ですごく大事にするんですね
このフラックス 流れ サンタティクというパリの言葉があります
サンタっていうのはフローという意味なんですね
フロー 英語でこのフラックスという言葉があるので
ちょっと難しい言葉なんですけどね
で フラックスというのは無常という意味も入ってますけどね
で フローは皆様よく知っている言葉というのはカランタなんですね
これはこのどっちにも入ってない説明で
だからものは流れるんですね
だけど横に流れるとずっと頭に浮かんじゃうんだから理解しにくいんだけど
やっぱり縦に関係なくちゃいけないんです
そこはすごい難しいんだけどね
もうしょうがないんだけど
だから心っていうのはもう流れているんです
ずっと そこでこの流れの法則っていうのは
いつでも 前のものは次のものの状態を決めちゃうんですね The
past and the preceding
先というんですか 先のといった後と言うんですか
熟だから 熟だから過ぎたものとね
もう これはやっぱりもう人間の言葉で言うもんじゃないんで
もうすっごいこの もう知ってはいるんだけど
なかなか言葉にならないんです
これ あの 我々 知ってる世界のもとで反対だからね
一応この一次元的には説明しますけどもね
いや 何か流れると で 次にどのように流れるべきかということは
前の 一歩前の流れで決めちゃうんですね
それも普通の物理的な法則でも同じことなんですね
ですから 瞬間の過去が今の瞬間の形をほぼ方向性決めちゃうんです
ただ それだけの原因で
我々はここの流れをある一方の方向へ決めちゃうんです
例えば さんざん仏教を勉強したり
貪瞋痴のことを勉強したりとかね
それで心の中でも貪瞋痴はもう生まれないように
もう生まれてもすぐすぐ消えるようにとか
そういういろんな訓練などをして
常に心が不貪不瞋痴の方向へ行くようにとか
常に無常を見られるようにとか
もうすごい頑張ってありとあらゆるところでダムやらいろんなものを作ってこの流れを変えちゃうんですね
変えちゃったら 瞬時に原因比率心から何が入ろうとも
この流れ法則が影響を与えちゃって
あの善進化と不善進化になるようになっちゃうんです
ですから この訓練 心の訓練というのは大事なポイントで
例えばこれはこんなに難しく
この本当に厳密に心理学で喋ると
この絶対人間の知識を超えてますから
どうしようもないんだけど
俗的に喋れば誰でもわかることなんです
もう例えばもう喧嘩ばっかし
恨み憎しみ ああだこうだばっかしやってる人々にの間にバラの花 1本入っちゃったと
その人何するかというと
もうそれで次の人を刺そうとするんですね
それでもいいんだから
例えばバラの花のところで捕まって
あの人をそれでぶん殴るかもしれませんし
そこですごくもうみんな仲良くニコニコとした楽しい雰囲気の中で
美しい環境の中でグループがいるんだと
そこにバラの花 1本開けたら
みんなああ これ良いですね
じゃあこちらにちゃんと置いておきましょうとか
その人々はそれほど喜びを感じちゃう
互いにものすごく憎しみあって
喧嘩し合ったりしているところにバラの花を持って行っちゃったら
それを武器になっちゃって
互いに殴り合ったりするということでしょ
瞬時にそうなっちゃうんだよね
なぜそうなったかというと
その今までの心の流れの方向性が次のことも決めてしまっちゃう
だから心 いくらこれは自然法則やもう宇宙の法則やと言ったっても
確実に訓練の大事さ 修行の大事さっていうのは確実にあるんです
もう科学の世界でも ただそんなもんだよと思って黙っていたって意味がないし
頑張っちゃえば変化も起こるし
重いものは絶対空は飛べませんよと言ったっても
やっぱりもう何か法則考えちゃうと飛べるようになるんだから
それで空は飛べるものを見てやったら
鳥なんか飛べてる 飛んでるんではない
鳥も重いんではないかと
見たところで 鳥の重さよりは体の大きさがすごい
でっかいんだと それからこういう
こういう こういう こういう方向性のものは変わっているんだと
我々も同じことを使えば飛ぶと決まっちゃいますからね
ですから このそれも修行なんですね
飛行機作ることも 物理学世界の
そこで心の場合も同じく法則さえ理解しておけば
修行ということで まあ修行という言葉作らなくて使わなくていいし
いわゆる訓練ということで
この方向性へも変えられますということ
それであのまあ悪い不善
いじく心のれお受心・すりど心・かくてい心があっても
色形心は清浄心になることはあり得ます
時間ですね あ ただランナーという言葉を説明しなかったね
可笑縁いじく心という言葉
そこであのまあこれで終わります
物質がこの十七刹那を生まれているし
生きているし そこで十五刹那の間はここ私にはそれ見えるし
そこで見えるセットがこの色形心七つ
エネルギー場七つ生まれたらもう認識仕事終わり
認識仕事終わっても もしまた一刹那
二刹那ぐらい あの見た対象がそこにいるならば
なんとなく心がまだそこら辺に付いていて
そこで対象が消えちゃった
心もそこで無明心になってしまうんだよ
その最後にまだいるんですか？ということで
ちょっと心はそこから離れなくなっちゃうんですね
それは可笑縁と呼ぶんですね
それもいじく心なんです
じゃあそれではもっと詳しい説明はまた次回にあります
二回どこまで  [背景音]